avec vous Emmanuel chasse bonjour je
disais tout à l'heure notre
correspondante à vous êtes de passage
par Paris on en profite le chef de
l'État qui a donc confirmé cette
nouvelle aide de la France à l'Ukraine
c'est un signal fort aujourd'hui c'est
un signal fort alors déjà c'est une
bonne nouvelle du côté ukrainien
puisqu'on voit qu'il y a vraiment une
stratégie de se tourner maintenant vers
des accords bilatéraux à un moment où
c'est vrai qu'il y a un peu une
incertitude quant à la suite des des de
l'aide du soutien occidental à l'Ukraine
on avait vu Richi sunac le Premier
ministre britanque se rendre à Kiev
maintenant nous avons Emmanuel Macron
qui va s'y rendre également pour
finaliser un un accord c'est très
important pour l'Ukraine en ce moment au
moment où les bombardements et bien il
continuent sur l'ensemble du pays on a
vu hier voladimir Zelenski justement
faire le déplacement cette année jusqu'à
Davos pour s'assurer de la la continuité
de de l'aide de ses de ses alliés il en
est question aujourd'hui he tout à fait
ce discours était extrêmement fort on a
vu le président volodimir Zelenski
vraiment rappeler à son auditoire que
cette guerre ne concernait pas seulement
l'Ukraine et et la Russie mais qu'au
contraire c'était un conflit qui était
déjà global dans ce qu'il impliquait par
exemple pour les livraisons de
céréales au-delà de de l'Ukraine
également au niveau de la sécurité
européenne il a rappelé que l'armée
ukrainienne pour l'instant était la
seule à vraiment être en mesure de
combattre l'armée russe sur une ligne de
front aussi large et donc évidemment il
est allé à Davos donc première fois
qu'il y va en présentielle he depuis le
début de la guerre il était en visio
pour les suivantes il s'est vraiment
adressé à cette audience dans le but de
rappeler à ses alliés que l'Ukraine
avait plus que jamais besoin du soutien
de l'Occident parlons peut-être un peu
un peu terrain etmanuel on on
commémorera bientôt les les de ans de
l'offensive russe vous qui vivez à Kiev
vous intervenez régulièrement sur sur
nos antenes au plus près parfois des
frappes aussi au sein dans la capitale
ukrainienne il est fait de quoi le
quotidien la dernière fois que nous nous
étions parlé j'étais sur un site un
immeuble un bâtiment résidentiel qui
avait été frappé par un missile qui
était tombé juste à côté dont les éclats
avait détruit plusieurs appartements il
y a eu quatre morts sur ce site euh
c'est très étrange car à kif les gens
continuent de vivre à peu près
normalement tant qu'il n'y a pas
d'alertes mais quotidiennement il a ses
alertes aériennes il y en a une encore
ce matin le 2 le 2 janvier il y a eu
plus de 100 missiles et drones qui ont
été lancés en direction de la capitale
ukrainienne ainsi que dans la ville de
halkiv donc le quotidien est ponctué par
ces alertes par des explosions eu donc
c'est très difficile évidemment pour les
Ukrainiens de continuer cette vie qu'il
à laquelle il tente toutefois de donner
une certaine normalité mais évidemment
rien n'est normal depuis 2 ans en tant
que journaliste c'est difficile de
couvrir cette guerre vous êtes plusieurs
évolué sur le terrain on était tout à
l'heure avec avec uliver Krag euh c'est
c'est intense j'ai pas envie de de dire
que c'est difficile parce que moi j'ai
un passeport qui me permet de sortir du
pays lorsque je pense que c'est trop ce
n'est pas le cas de millions
d'Ukrainiens qui sont sur place mais
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui prend
bah vraiment au trip quand on se
réveille au son des explosions avec le
plafonnier qui tremble quand on ouvre
les rideaux qu'on voit des colonnes de
fumée quand on se dirige sur le site des
explosions qu'on voit des des colonnes
de fumées noir s'élevé à travers la
ville de quartiers résidentiels on
s'inquiète pour ses proches pour ses
amis pour ses collègues également donc
oui c'est pas un terrain facile mais
comme tous les terrains de guerre un mot
peut-être de l'état du moral des troupes
on va avoir évidemment l'occasion d'en
reparler au moment du du 2e anniversaire
qu'on qu'on marquera évidemment sur nos
sur nos antennes ils en sont où les
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui mais écoutez on a
beaucoup mis l'accent sur la fin d'année
sur un échec perçu de la contreoffensive
ukrainienne j'apporterai une petite
nuance sur cet échec supposé qui est
surtout perçu comme tel en Occident en
Ukraine on on soulève surtout un point
important qui est que l'armée
ukrainienne elle est quand même en
infériorité numérique en en infériorité
aussi en ce qui concerne le nombre
d'hommes sur le terrain par rapport à la
Russie et pourtant elle a réussi à
maintenir une ligne de front n'a pas
perdu de territoire significatif tout au
long de l'année 2003 donc pour les pour
les Ukrainiens c'est pas forcément vécu
comme un échec évidemment il y a uneord
c'est ça que vous êtes en train de dire
ils y croi encore il va bien que c'est
très difficile il voit bien que la ligne
de front n'a pas bougé depuis très
longtemps puisque les lignes de défense
russes sont très bien installé puisque
30 % du pays est miné ce qui retarde
aussi l'avancée des troupes ukrainiennes
néanmoins on a vu il y a quelques jours
on a vu des frappes de longue portée
donc dans le territoire russe donc sur
des infrastructures militaires nous dit
keV il y a également eu cette frappe
contre un avion radar qui est tombé en
mer d'Azov donc il y a aussi des succès
de l'armée ukrainienne et ceux-ci bien
ils sont célébrés par la population
ukrainienne on aura évidemment
l'occasion de le parler sur sur nos
antennes merci beaucoup Emmanuel chass
qu'on retrouvera donc très prochainement
en direct de Kiev au plus près euh du
terrain